en 1916 on a trouvé un produit moins
cher et plus efficace que les sens pour
faire fonctionner les voitures ça n'a
pas vraiment marché comme on aurait pu
l'espérer
[Musique]
nous somme en 1916 en plein pendant la
première guerre mondiale et aux états
unis
on manque de beaucoup de choses dont les
sentes donc l'on commence à dire
peut-être qu'il faudrait trouver quelque
chose d'autre pour faire fonctionner les
voitures et c'est là qu'arrive un
certain louis heinrich qui lui dit avoir
trouvé un lit pied magique louis
heinrich n'en est pas à ses premières
armes il faut dire que 70 ans mais il
pense avoir enfin trouvé ce qui va lui
permettre de faire fortune
il va convoquer une conférence de presse
en invitant tous les journalistes et
journalistes arrivent et voie d'une
voiture devant eux
on prend sa fameuse mixture un liquide
vert auquel y ajoute de l'eau est
ensuite y verse dans le réservoir
il démarre la voiture et ça fonctionne
et il faut dire que ce fameux liquide
coûte deux fois moins cher que l'essence
est beaucoup plus facile à trouver
plusieurs investisseurs se rendent
auprès de reinerie ch pour acheter sa
fameuse formule mais il veut rien savoir
pourquoi parce qu'il attend le gros
poisson et le gros poisson
il s'appelle henrie folle et vous savez
quoi il va venir le voir
henrie ford qui arrive devant heinrich
lui propose d'acheter sa formule il lui
dit non seulement j'achète la formule
mais je te donne une voiture donc
finalement heinrich peu profité d'une
retraite dorée
sauf que forment quand il revient dans
son usine il fait analyser la fameuse
mixture et l'aï va se rendre compte que
malheureusement pour lui ça coûte trois
fois plus cher que l'essence est pire
encore que la mixture de heinrich et
creuser pour le motard en gros ça coûte
plus cher puis ça détruit les voitures
disons que anouilh ford le père de
l'automobile moderne s'est fait
royalement avoir tout le monde peut se
faire avoir même les plus grands